the guardian of the all I did all this
they do no once more
withdraw your shadow from my domain no
no no no no no no no no don't don't
don't
did I see Dora yeah he said the guardian
of the [ __ ] orb or something
and I thought it was gonna come yeah but
you got a dagger the date that he wrote
when he started talking was the same
date that he said when he we started
playing the game part one and I'm
basically remembering stuff
and I want to find out we had still
haven't found out like why we're erased
our memory but I'm guessing that's what
we're finding out here
often menacing a ritual begin huh huh
tinderboxes thank you very much where do
we come from here
okay let's going here did you have to do
such a big chair maybe just to torture
people apparently this is the choir but
I'm guessing there's torture here as
well
oh no no no no no no no no no no no no
hey you know what no I saw a picture of
this part
picture yeah it was like related links
and I know you can see the monster here
that's good right now
[ __ ] yourself in this place you well if
you see now you won't see me you're such
an optimist Lance and [ __ ]
it oh I heard him behind me I think
can you teleport because I mean in the
scary movie made yeah he can kind of
teleport yeah II teleport into the room
yeah he's like scripted so he'll appear
at certain places I don't like this
place I can't see anything
can you see better now nope well then I
can't see anything either
isn't it Foley yeah it is foggy
you really want to lie to watch us it no
no
it's the monster blight I don't think so
but he has kind of bad vision now that
you mention it oh they were Cetina bucks
and use those for lighting up those oh
she's like matches yeah I keep hearing
stuff
everywhere
I don't like this place
you know what I would never play this
game I'm glad you're with me I get it
frightful play a little game
oh yeah it's told me about that actually
get afraid that I don't understand well
they have some yes I got afraid from
playing spell oh well I got afraid when
I played selling when I was little yeah
I mean I got like heart beating real
fast and I was Eddie a horse
it's a [ __ ] cow what the hell are you
cheating me that's nice you should Aggie
what the [ __ ]
whoa do I still have the dagger no I
don't well
Moo says the cow the traitor did not
know what to think of the brass Bowl oh
it's a bull sorry as he was forced to
enter it only when he the heat of fire
began to scorch his skin and cook his
flesh did you realize it was to be his
tomb his screams of pain echoed inside
the brass chamber and it traveled
through the complex instrument which was
the Bulls head then outside them the man
could hear the brazen bull bellow wow
that's a sick message it's like an oven
or something yeah oh damn I thought they
were just gonna be like I was a hiding
place yeah exactly one time I had to
hide in a closet when the monster came
and it worked yeah Edward
oh oh whoa oh oh
heíd boat where there yeah that's good I
don't think he's gonna come though
I hope that
I can't open it now
well is that good for this scary
the tissue is quite soft and could be
possible to break open
Oh Oh what I didn't expect it to work
what is it poison gland my gland falling
more poisonous mushroom Oh lovely
yeah that can be you so so much
hey you pick up the weirdest stuff in
this game and then you make use of them
in the weirdest ways
I guess I'm gonna keep going in here
look out that's not funny dude push
those tinderboxes what this place in
those tinderbox yeah that I oh oh oh
he's out there
oh [ __ ] you sir you look hot wish in the
corner where you can pause oh [ __ ] well
there's the [ __ ] place to rob I can't
see him yeah I hope it's not gonna
teleport Hey
I knew it I [ __ ] knew it
no [ __ ] sir you still there can you
see him at all
no he's right there I can't see him now
but I saw him earlier he was walking
towards me hello
my stereo I think he's gone I what scene
I don't Shh that's for [ __ ] sure I'll
see sanity huh oh she's it's come down
every time you see him your sanity goes
down so you know because yeah like I
said earlier if your sanity goes to zero
you will like brush your head to do
floor and if you and like I said your
sanity increases every time
no decreases every time you see the
monster so in case that happens when you
see the monster you're pretty much
[ __ ] up
don't want that happening [ __ ] your
hating so much
let's go in here oh and trends so this
is where I came from
or is it I don't remember you're
probably gonna meet them again that
aren't you inside ashore right now yeah
I think I am so then you should go back
to anyway oh wait here's the door I
never your visit looks nice
already lighten up and what the [ __ ] is
that
can't even burn out yeah
this looks like torture thingy I hate
this game I knew that was gonna happen
the forger stood absolutely still the
casket had been closed but a faint light
made its way inside a myriad of spikes
pointed at him glittering as they waited
for his body to slip just for a moment
his knee jerked and he felt blood tickle
trickled down his leg in pain his head
fell slightly forward it took him a
while to realize his eye had ruptured
and began to lead yeah yeah [ __ ] here
yeah those guys watch
Oh an orb orb piece awesome dude we
collect an ore piece from the other the
cow no we did and I think there's a
orbits there there's got to be an
officer okay
I think you have to go back there
[ __ ] else will appear here yeah he will
probably appear again
it's like scripted took place so if you
posit it it seems that way yes oh the
place where I was before we started
paying I looked behind me and there was
nothing there and then I opened the door
and then looked behind me and he was
right there so yeah it's still scary I
mean it was even more scary in the
beginning when I didn't know he was
scripted I thought it was like
patrolling and [ __ ] oh [ __ ] heck in here
I think we're good
I did hear them though it's so foggy I
can't see [ __ ]
and how does fine you I socks yeah I
have something to do with the orb so I
guess that's how he finds me I have no
[ __ ] idea see that play them do you
mean like game McKenna's more like how
we actually finds me I don't know yeah
if you look if I what maybe there's more
than one yeah I think there is actually
more than one because we saw a different
one earlier you haven't seen that though
he had I like a robot arm or something
there's got to be something here
can't open
I'm just gonna use everything because
I'm [ __ ] [ __ ] Hema
no can't use it that way oh here it is
I know that was a part oh you luck you
went that yeah I guess we got file yeah
so what does it look like you can fit
these
there's gotta be a room I missed I feel
like there is that's a very I'd be real
after a very what ugly ugly yeah it
changes color apparently so that's why
oh [ __ ] did I come from you yeah are you
sure
nope me neither I can't pulse here or
can I
No
okay trying to help me no because I have
don't have any sense of direction no I
can't see entity
No oh that oh he's behind me down here
in the right direction
I heard him behind me it was very loud
let's check it out
and try confront
no I don't want to do that that's just
stupid
I hear them over there
walk this way
all scary music never good news
is there oh I haven't been in here right
turn the [ __ ] [ __ ] up hey hey here's
the thing they break in the mood man or
simply stretched across there's so many
shots to the spa it's [ __ ] wheel
are by this Paul